what's going on guys this is rob and uh
deadpool 3 in the marvel cinematic
universe oh my god this is gonna be
it's gonna be so amazing i'm so excited
for this i'm so hyped for this
um something that i do wanna i do wanna
throw out here uh that i do wanna tell
you guys about and it
really would mean a lot to me um the the
pop culture explained channel that
myself and my staff were working on
it's gotten a really good reception so
far right the stanley explained video is
one that you guys
absolutely loved and based on that we're
gonna start doing more stuff like that
so i think the next
celebrity explained that we have coming
out is chadwick boseman
um i feel like now's a good time to do
it right i didn't want to make it seem
like i was trying to cash grab on
chadwick's name that's not really what i
was interested in doing
um and i think enough times enough time
has passed that we could make a video
about him honoring his legacy
without disrespecting him by trying to
make money off his name right because
the channel's not really monetized at
the moment so we wouldn't really be
making any money anyway
but i think he's he's an iconic actor
from a variety of different different
films but especially for us as marvel
fans um
he was a great black panther and and i
really feel like it's a good idea to
kind of
honor his legacy and and the
contributions he made especially to the
black panther mythos
um but then we're also going to be
covering stuff for like one division
with the show coming out this week so
you know kind of explaining the episodes
things like that that a lot of you guys
uh may probably have some questions
about because of you know
the nature of the show is probably gonna
be pretty pretty bonkers
i'm not gonna lie i think it's gonna be
kind of wild but uh it would really mean
a lot to me if you guys went over to pop
culture explained
uh youtube.com popcultureexplained and
checked it out right you'll find a link
to the channel down in the description
but um but deadpool 3 in the mcu right
this is cool this is this is this is
really really cool
and in fact i think deadpool 3 and the
mcu will probably be the best thing to
happen
to the mcu and here's the reason why i
say that right before you guys
where you guys freak out you know rob
mcu doesn't need saving before you guys
freak out
here's what i mean by that right the
marvel cinematic universe movies
um are great films right they're really
really fun films the problem with the
marvel films is they're formulaic you
can set your watch by a marvel movie
right it's just
and and the formulas worked right it's a
multi-billion dollar
uh you know franchise i mean i don't
think anybody could really look
at the marvel cinematic universe and
begin to even make the argument that
their formula doesn't work right it
works
well and their movies are fun but
deadpool is a whole different beast
right i mean when deadpool 1 came out uh
it was nuts right i mean how many of you
guys how many of you guys loved deadpool
1. right
answer that question down in the
comments how many of you guys love
deadpool 1 right
deadpool one was amazing it was an
amazing movie because it was such a
break away from
all the other comic book films that we'd
seen right this guy who's just kind of
like you know
just sort of do my own thing and that
was always the nature of deadpool where
he just defied
societal or i guess comic book norms
where he defied all these comic book
norms and just
did his own thing i think deadpool in
the mcu is genius
because he's kind of just like the the
adhd kid
right like the kid that just can't pay
attention is always bouncing around off
the walls and things like that
that's deadpool man so like like i'm a
little sad because we won't get to see
deadpool alongside like chris evans
captain america
and like tony stark you know robert
downey jr tony stark which would have
been hilarious like could you imagine
like tony stark and robert downey jr
like i'm sorry uh
tony stark and captain america having a
conversation
and like here comes deadpool right just
being all goofy and nonsensical and just
annoying the hell out of both of them it
would have been amazing
it would have been hilarious but we're
not gonna get to see that it doesn't
mean that it's gonna suck
but we're not gonna get to see that and
it's gonna be kind of disappointing
if i'm a betting man um assuming they do
secret wars that's how you'll get to see
captain america and iron man come back
right like steve rogers might be de-aged
by like the beyonder to the point where
he was younger and then he'll be brought
into secret wars
and maybe tony stark will be brought
back to life to fight during secret wars
and then die at the end of secret wars
again or something like that i don't
really know
but uh but deadpool you know it's it's
it's cool right it's a really exciting
thing here's my question
does that mean that we have to remaster
uh deadpool kills the marvel universe
deadpool killestrated and deadpool kills
deadpool does that mean we have to we
have to redo those
we have to go back and remaster those
because those stories were funny as hell
like they were they were they were
hilarious stories
um but i'm really excited about this man
especially the fact that it's rated r
because here was my biggest fear my
biggest fear was that with deadpool
in the mcu that they were going to tone
them down and they were going to make
the movie like pg-13 because the
entirety of the mcu is pg-13
and and there's there's truth to the old
statement if it's not broke don't fix it
and deadpool was not only not broken he
worked fantastic right so it doesn't
really make any sense to edit it like to
tone it down or change it
not only that ryan reynolds is the one
apparently overseeing and handling the
script
according to the to the articles i've
read so it's essentially
all the stuff that worked with fox just
being brought over and and literally
just being done in the mcu right it's
literally foggy and then just like okay
so what did you guys do when you were
working on the movie with fox and ryan
reynolds and all them are like we did
this this this this and this
and foggy's like okay keep doing that
we'll see you guys in like three years
and that's it
that's all we really get uh the movie
hasn't even remotely started finishing
it
started started production yet right and
i think that the
the estimates were basically like we
would see it in like 2023 maybe you know
at the absolute earliest we'll probably
end up seeing it in like 2024
so we've got about three years before
we'll see deadpool in the mcu
but this creates all kinds of
possibilities right because we know that
people love deadpool
we know that people love the deadpool
movie i love the deadpool movie both one
and two
and so what it does is it gives us the
potential to see like
deadpool cameos over the course of the
next three years and that's gonna be
badass right it's gonna be cool
because the deadpool cameos are like
random and sometimes they're nonsensical
and they don't really seem you know
there's they're just kind of bonkers
right like imagine if we got a deadpool
cameo
during like the original avengers film
by joss whedon right like imagine some
situation where like new york's popping
off like
guys are getting attacked like you know
so it's like getting blown up you know
just
exploding all over the place you know
and all that kind of stuff and then it
just like cuts to a diner
and deadpool's like eating in that diner
while like the ceiling's falling like
dust is going everywhere and all that
kind of stuff
and he kind of muses to himself like you
know i should probably get out there and
do something
um but i'm not really owned by disney
yet so i'll have to wait until they buy
me you know or something like that like
if you it would have been a hilarious
little candle just something small
that's no longer than like 45 seconds to
a minute
and like that's it right and it'd be
kind of funny you see like deadpool in
the background
you know or something something along
those lines you know like like it'd be
hilarious like you got spiderman three
you know and like something's going on
peter parker is doing whatever he's
doing you know and like deadpool's like
hey dude i'm a huge fan can i get an
autograph like
like while peter parker's in this
apartment or something like that like
deadpool like
like busts into his apartment like he's
like sneak like climbs up the wall
you know and then like goes in like it's
like his big assassin mission like he's
like climbing up the wall
you know then like he breaks into peter
parker's place and him and all him and
peter almost get into a fight he's like
calm down man uh i'm new here to disney
i'm a big fan
can i get an autograph right it's those
little cameos that are amazing like in
deadpool 2 when he was in the xavier
mansion and like
they brought back the whole cast like
james mcavoy and all them and like they
were hiding in a they were
hiding from deadpool they were like
avoiding deadpool right like those
little moments
are what really made deadpool shine and
the reality is that the mcu is great
it's a formula that works but you can
set your watch by it right you can set
your watch
by a marvel cinematic universe movie you
know what you get going into it right
and so because of that like deadpool
would offer this great reprieve
from these otherwise formulaic films and
that's that's what's so awesome about
this man is because
i'm excited to see stuff like i'm like
i'm excited to see stuff man like like
if they could get hugh jackman back as
wolverine do that would be the cherry on
top that's exactly what that would be
man dude that movie
dude man dude deadpool and hugh jackman
in the same movie together dude that
[ __ ] would slap
that that would be absolutely nuts it
would be it'd be amazing
would be fire but like there's there's a
ton of possibilities here
right there's some great possibilities
here and and that's what makes me that's
what makes me so excited right deadpool
deadpool in the marvel cinematic
universe
it's finally happening i don't know if
we're really going to get anything like
uh like you know x-force or anything
along those lines
um but i'm hoping to see some cool stuff
right like you had the invisible guy the
invisible man in deadpool 2
who turned out to be brad pitt and you
only found out when he died
like it's stuff like that right just
these small little these small little
moments as well
god i'm so excited man it's gonna be
it's gonna be amazing see i keep telling
people i kept telling people right
people were just like man now that
infinity war and endgame has happened
it's the death of the marvel cinematic
universe and i'm like no
no son it's just beginning right it's
it's just it's just beginning man
because here's the thing
anybody who's been on this channel for
any measure of time knows that like
thanos with the infinity gauntlet
who cares man like he's like he's like
not even that powerful at all right i
mean
he could do some stuff and it's kind of
cool but like we know characters who
would obliterate thanos with the
like even with the infinity gauntlet
that was like here i come with the
infinity gauntlet you know
the the hardest choices wire require the
strongest wills and here's molecule man
like no they don't either and then just
snaps his fingers and that's the end of
thanos like it's that's
it's just it's it's it'd be amazing
right i mean there's characters out
there who would just dwarf
thanos with the power in the infinity
the marquee of death the market the
marquis
marquis of death man clyde winship just
walk just walk into the multiverse just
like
done done universe dead universe dead
you know
he's he's just he's just sitting there
like eating a burrito you know he's he's
eating the candy bar you know just
dead you know just like wiping out whole
universes i mean it's it's it's crazy
the level of power when it comes to
characters out there
and so like the mcu here's the thing
guys for anybody out there who's new to
comics and hasn't really
and is just kind of coming out of the
movies here's the thing to understand
everything you've seen in the last 10
years in the marvel cinematic universe
is the tip of the tip of the tip of the
very very very very tip
of the iceberg marvel hasn't even begun
to scratch the surface on the things
that they can do
it's it's crazy like this is this is
this is nuts
i would wager the stuff we're gonna see
in the future of the mcu
will dwarf the things we've seen for the
last 10 years and people will just be
like oh my god you're like
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers i mean like deadpool was in
secret invasion he's literally the one
who saved the day
right like well yeah kind of not really
i mean he technically was the one
who won secret invasion who like
defeated the the scrolls and then norman
osborne like basically intercepted the
info and then like made it look like he
saved the day then like he became
director of shield
norman osborne like the green goblin
that norman osborne the guy was a dick
like i mean there's there's so many
things i can do in the marvel in the in
the marvel cinematic universe now and
that's that's what's so cool about this
is because it gives us the ability to
see a character that we know and love
crossing over with other characters that
we know and love and it's hard to
explain but as a comic book fan you're
just excited for it
you're just excited for man it's it's
exciting it's exciting it's
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is an exciting moment right it is it is
it is an exciting moment
it's a really cool moment so i don't
know let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section right like
give me your thoughts
down in the comment section what do you
guys think about the idea of deadpool in
the marvel cinematic universe
i'm excited for it i think it's going to
be awesome but if you guys are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob corp if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like don't forget
to go check out pop culture explained
and i will catch you all later
you say